mais mon tempérament n'est jamais de
m'exonérer de quoi que ce soit mais j'ai
un principe simple quand on mène une
bataille on doit être uni pour la gagner
et je pense que toutes celles et ceux
qui cherchent déjà à faire des procès
alors que nous n'avons pas gagné la
guerre sont irresponsables
le temps viendra de la responsabilité ce
temps viendra
et il est légitime et démocratique et à
ce moment là la transparence complète
devra être refaite mais j'appelle
d'abord à la dignité et à l'esprit de
responsabilité celles et ceux qui
construisent des certitudes avec les
connaissances d'aujourd'hui quand ça
n'était pas celle d'hier
vous savez je pourrai retrouver les
paroles de toutes celles et ceux qui
vous explique les grandes difficultés
qui quelques jours avant mon premier mac
première allocution du 12 mars expliqué
qu' il serait indigne de reporter les
élections municipales qui tout ça est
une mise en scène du gouvernement et va
trop loin
donc tout le monde a appris et nous
apprenons tous avec beaucoup d'humilité
parce que cette pandémie est inédite
donc il faut avoir de l'humilité tous
ceux qui agissent
c'est ce que je demande au gouvernement
ce que je m'appliquais moi même ceux qui
commentent donc l'humilité est de mise
et ne revoyons pas les semaines passées
à l'aune des connaissances d'aujourd'hui
elles ont quasiment changer chaque jour
et vous le savez bien vous qui informés
et on apprend chaque jour de tête crise
partout dans le monde
ensuite c'est un principe de méthode
quand on mène un combat on doit tous
être unis
donc moi je crois à l'unité j'appelle
l'ensemble des françaises et des
français cette unité
elle est indispensable pour gagner cette
bataille ensuite viendra le temps des
responsabilités et on regardera tous et
tout ce qu'on pouvait mieux faire ce
qu'on aurait pu mieux faire et on devra
le faire là aussi avec un principe de
justice à l'égard de tous les choix
passé quel que soit d'ailleurs les
responsables politiques parce qu'on peut
pas demander à des gens d'avoir pris des
décisions il ya cinq ou dix ans qui ne
pouvait pas anticiper ce qu'on vient de
vivre
donc faut aussi avoir tiré un esprit de
justice à l'égard de tous et tout quand
on vit quelque chose qui est inédit peut
pas demander aux gens d'avoir prévu à 10
ans
donc j'essaie d'appliquer aux autres que
je m'applique à moi même mais le temps
en tout cas et pas aujourd'hui à sa voix
a assigné les responsabilités le temps
il est à s'unir à multiplier les
solidarités a multiplié les innovations
on voit d'ailleurs partout dans le pays
et à se tenir les coudes pour terrasser
ce virus c'est ça ce que j'attends d'eux